our next guest coming up rabbi shapiro
are you related at all to ben shapiro
uh i am not and if i was i would not
admit it
[Laughter]
so when your typical jew sees such a
huge gathering of 15 000 jews and
so would ben shapiro fit under that
category
if you ask them that the jews and
muslims lived in peace
for for over a thousand years
okay so you so you're a specialist in uh
jewish sharia law it's not islam and
it's not
it's not muslims against jews that's the
main thing we have to tell people
alhamdulillah
assalamu alaikum greetings and peace
welcome to the dean show i'm eddie your
host
how you guys doing good to have you back
with us every week
here on a deenshow subscriber if you
haven't already hit that notification
bell so you can get all the latest
episodes sent directly to you
go ahead and subscribe right now hit
that notification bell help us get our
numbers back up did you know that
many years ago the dean show when we
started 2006 we used to broadcast for
many years on the khalifa clothing
channel
currently known as digital minbot so
we're trying to get our numbers back up
because the channel at that time got
closed then we started the official d
show channel we're trying to get our
numbers back up to where they should be
and that's this number here 855 combined
what we currently have 442
we should be over a million 200
000 subscribers help us to get our
numbers
back to where they should be with that
small setback that we had many years ago
you guys can help us by subscribing
right now and hitting that notification
bell
thank you very much enjoy the rest of
this show and don't forget to support us
on our patreon page
our next guest coming up rabbi shapiro
his congregation is in queens new york
he is a specialist in jewish history
and jewish law sharia law
and he's an author of several books my
next guest special guest
rabbi how are you shapiro i'm great
thanks so much for having me on
yeah thank you for uh being with us when
i was interview introducing you i said
in uh jewish sharia law is that correct
that's absolutely true in fact one of
our great sages rabbi saju gon
who was egyptian he lived in philim he
used he used to write in arabic his
jewish works philosophical works
and for the word that's translated torah
or teachings he uses the word sharia
plural
okay so you so you're a specialist in uh
jewish sharia law and a historian
academic and you're here with us on the
dean's show
i am thank you so much thank you i want
to get into this next clip
we're about to begin a historic event
now this is you
is this correct this is that is me i
recognize that it will not be an
educational
lesson lectures given by experts in
judaism
about judaism in particular the
incompatibility between judaism and
zionism
many jews believe wrongly that zionism
is either part of judaism or
is compatible with judaism or is even
the main part of judaism all of those
are actually false
zionism was created to negate judaism
zionism was created to replace judaism
the differences between zionism and
judaism are vast they are vast and
profound
the propaganda that the zionists have
churned out for the past hundred years
have confused and conflated zionism and
judaism such that
when the average person walks down the
street he thinks that the state of
israel is the jewish state he thinks
that zionism is judaism
and he doesn't know the difference this
group of jews here
are students of the students of the late
satmar rabbi rabjoe teitelbaum
who was the greatest disseminator of the
clarity regarding the difference between
judaism and zionism
so tell us about this uh gathering here
you fifteen thousand these are like
students of students of you mentioned
uh the the the scholar there the rabbi
uh there's students there scholars there
tell us a little bit about this event
that you were at
sure there were there were two such
events actually this one was a nassau
coliseum a parallel one a taking that
took place at a different time
was in the barclays center in brooklyn
basically there were protests against
israel's well the one in barclay was a
protest against israel's
attempts to draft the orthodox jews the
yeshiva students into their army
and the one in nassau coliseum was just
a general educational
event to teach the
students there the congregation the jews
that they need to learn the difference
between judaism and zionism in depth
and regularly let me ask you this
question rabbi
shapiro is anti-zionism and
anti-semitism synonymous
no that's may i say it's stupid that's
exactly what it is it's absolute
nonsense
it's very simple first of all
zionism is not judaism and even if
zionism was judaism if somebody doesn't
like my religion doesn't make him an
anti-semite there are plenty of
religions that i don't like there are
probably certain religions that you
don't like
if i don't like somebody's religion that
doesn't make me a hater
if i don't like somebody's essential
characteristics something he's born with
if i judge somebody by his
the color of his skin or his nationality
or the way that he
some something that he's born with then
that's hate but if i judge somebody by
his lifestyle choices
including his religion there are all
sorts of satanic religions and stuff
that does that's not hate speech that's
an opinion just any ideology
is is um subject to opposition and
zionism is just an ideology
even if it would be part of judaism
which it's not now
zionism not only is not part of judaism
but it's actually it contravenes judaism
you see uh zionism was invented in the
19th century
and it was designed to change the
definition of what a jew is
the the formula that the zionists give
which actually capsule capsulizes
zionism very well
and it also is used by them to explain
why anti-zionism is anti-semitism
benjamin netanyahu
the former prime minister of israel
thank god he's former
uh uses this in his book called
among the family of nations uh he says
that saying i'm
anti-zionist but i'm not anti-jew is
saying
is the same as saying i'm anti america
the existence of america but i'm not
against the american nationality
in other words as avigdor lieberman puts
it on israel's website and
mfa the ministry of foreign affairs
japan is to the japanese what francis to
the french what israel is to the
jews now mind you
the real formulation is that japan is to
the japanese but francis to the french
what israel is to the israelis
there is only one country in the world
and that's israel one country in the
world
that claims to be the nation-state of
people that are not its citizens that
never were its citizens don't plan on
being its citizens
it means two things if israel would be
the country of the israelis that means
whether you're jewish or not
israel's your country but because israel
claims that it's the state of the jews
not the israelis you could be an israeli
citizen but there's a nation-state law
that says
that national self-determination rights
only apply to the jews that means a
if you are an israeli citizen but you're
not jewish israel is not your
nation-state
two it means that if you are a jew such
as myself who does not live in israel
i'm not an israeli citizen my father's
family is from poland
on my mother's side they're from england
and russia this means that
israel claims because i'm born jewish
that israel is my
state and that's absolutely not true i
have nothing to do with some country in
the middle east
what zionism did is change the
definition of jew or in their mind
from a religion to a nationality
it's very simple the definition of jew
according to judaism according to the
way jews have identified all throughout
history
is quite simple there's a story of the
jewish people in the bible
god gave the torah to the jews on mount
sinai
very simple god gave moses the law and
he gave it to the jews
that's it now if you change god
we're a monotheistic religion if you
change god like the old pagans did
you're changing the religion of judaism
to another religion
if you don't believe in our god if you
don't believe in our law
you add a new testament for example like
the christians did you changed our
religion
the zionists changed the third part of
that equation the jewish people
god gave the law to the jews the pagans
changed what
god is the christians changed with the
law is
and the zionists changed what the jews
are
the jews they said are not somebody that
was created on mount
mount sinai that was enjoined by god
deputized into the religion
to follow the torah that's what a jew is
if the law says
you are obligated to follow the torah
that makes you jewish
if not not your father's jewish and your
mother's not jewish you're not jewish
that's that's religious doctrine the
zionist said no no we don't like that we
don't want that
that makes trouble people don't like
jews because of the religion
we're going to become jews but not
religious wise we're going to become a
nationality see in the 19th century
nationalism helped a lot of people the
balkan states and so on
and they said we're going to transform a
jewish identity
from a religion to a nationality
so here's what they did they said first
we have to give the jewish people
national characteristics
the jews had no national characteristics
we did not have a common land
israel is a holy land very important to
know israel is to the jews a holy land
not a national homeland a homeland means
the place where the nation was born and
indeed in israel's
language in modern hebrew homeland is
called moledet
which means the place you're born in
israel's declaration of independence it
says the jewish people were born here
that's false according to judaism the
jewish people were born
at mount sinai according to zionism
the jewish people were born when joshua
led the jews into
israel if they actually believe that
which they don't but at least in them
what they claim is mythology that's when
judaism started
they claimed the jews were born in that
land they changed the concept of a holy
land
with to a national homeland difference
is that if it's a homeland
it doesn't matter who has sovereignty
over it jerusalem and the holy land is
just as holy
when the turks owned it or the ottomans
when the british owned it
when the romans owned it in fact today
part of lebanon southern lebanon is the
holy land
it's considered the the land of our
forefathers and a lot which is part of
israel is not part of the holy land so
if you're living in a lot you're not
you're considered as as if you're not
living in the holy land it's the same as
you'd be living in paris
but in southern lebanon somewhere um
south of beirut i'm not exactly sure
what what town would be there but
somewhere southern lebanon
that's considered the holy land they
changed it to a
national homeland sons for some reason
that the jews therefore need to have
sovereignty over it which is false
not only do the jews not don't care
about sovereignty over it
it's holy no matter what um the jews are
not allowed to have sovereignty over it
before the messiah comes but that's
really beside the point they gave the
jews in national language
hebrew jews haven't spoken hebrew for
thousands of years
literally really even in the days when
the strong
temple two thousand years ago when we
lived in
uh the holy lands with the temple uh
we spoke aramaic i don't mean to
interrupt you when i was watching uh
your lecture has zionism hijacked
judaism
that was one of my questions i was going
to ask you you you talked about this in
that lecture that
language of the jews was aramaic times
the jews
spoke hebrew in biblical time abraham
moses
they spoke hebrew however that's not
what made us into a people that wasn't
our national language the way english
makes
uh englishmen into english there was a
professor that had a very interesting uh
observation every language reflects the
name of the people that speak it
china chinese england english america
also english
mexico spain spanish etc but in
hebrew and judaism hebrew is not called
jewish
it's called latin which means the holy
language
because it wasn't it wasn't the national
language could be we spoke it once we
did in biblical times
but that's not what made us into a
people during the times of the second
uh temple we spoke aramaic okay
and but the zionist said we need
to give the jews a language so we're
going to create a modern hebrew language
and they actually created a language
a biblical hebrew which is the only
hebrew that we spoke
has a few hundreds it's in the hundreds
the amount of root
words it has modern hebrew has like
thousands and thousands it's mostly
invented taken from other languages
uh but they said jews have to speak
hebrew and this was way before they
created a state
jews needed a he uh language they
created a flag for the jews jews never
had a flag because we're not a
nationality
the kurds have a flag even though they
don't have a country we didn't care what
language we spoke jews in
spain spoke spanish or latino jews
but some jews spoke yiddish the jews in
in syria
arabic i have syrian jewish orthodox
friends they refer to god as allah
and they still use arabic uh phrases
i learned from them lived in china he
spoke chinese that's all
you know what the language of the jews
is is the holy torah it's our studies
the contents not
the style in which you say it if you
speak
positive about god about the religion
about the torah
if you study the torah you ask a
question about it you give a new insight
to it
that's the language of the jews the
zionists hated that
so so they made us they made the jews
into they claimed the jews are a
nationality
and that israel is a country that and
china is based on two claims claim
number one
the jews are nationality uh political
people
which the first person which was
invented mostly by ein regrets
two that israel is the country of the of
that people
both of those are false okay i want to
get a bunch of questions in here
um since we have you rabbi shapiro are
you related at all to ben shapiro
uh i am not and if i was i would not
admit
so you know who i'm talking about i know
exactly who you're talking about yes
okay jews who are orthodox such as him
who are also zionists
we consider zionism the idea that user
nationality a form of idol worship
would you say that again consider
zionism which is the ideology that says
jews are a nation
yeah as idol worship wow same as if you
change
god you change the jewish people it's
idol worship
now somebody who's a zionist who's also
an orthodox jew
is no different than the orthodox jews
in biblical times who
worshipped the baal who were religious
jews
that also worshiped idols yeah they are
religious idol worshipers
so would ben shapiro fit under that
category oh yes if if he's a zionist you
know i mean i'd have to ask him because
we we have a rule that we judge people
favorably unless we prove them guilty
but if he admits
that he believes the jews are a
nationality he believes in zionism
then yes he certainly would absolutely
be an idol worshiper if he believes that
the state of israel is the state of the
jews
the nation of the jews yes that's idol
worship no question about it what are
some of his main views that you've seen
publicly that he talks about that he
expresses
and have you ever watched him and then
how would a conversation between you and
him go
um i have not watched him i have a clip
of him once
um which i play often you know that
that item that i just quoted from
benjamin netanyahu in his book that
the reason why anti-zionism is
anti-semitism is because
um you can't say that you don't want
israel to exist and still you want the
jews to exist
it's like saying america so ben shapiro
said the exact same thing
i'm not saying he plagiarized it from
netanyahu but i'm not saying he didn't
and i use that as an example country
that still val
him and netanyahu both said the same
thing
i guess by the way it means the
benjamins are a problem those two
and um they it's both
zionism and it's both absolutely against
judaism
what do we have here i have a little
clip from from ben
see let's see what he has to say i live
in a country that still
values dissent and protest that's much
more than we can say right now
for the apartheid state of israel whoa
not sure where that came from
and um that's a lie but i think we'll
save that live for another time since we
actually have other topics
to get to suffice to say that muslims in
israel have more rights than muslims any
place
in the middle east by a long shot we
often hear this you often hear this
what do you say to something like that
okay so first i
have to tell you my policy on
the jews relationship to the
israel-palestinian conflict
okay and far be it from me
to tell the palestinians how to fight
their fight
not my job however if they would ask me
advice
this is what i would tell them
the the issue between israel and the
palestinians
is not merely an issue of behavior ben
shapiro and that was ariel gold i
believe
are talking about israel's behavior
behavior is a result of and is driven by
an ideology the ideology that justifies
israel's actions is that
israel is the state of the jews
that's zionism and just as you you you
you can't fight an enemy without
fighting the ideology that drives them
you you can't fight stalin you need to
fight communism also
and you know how whenever there's a war
you drop these flyers over
enemy territory to tell them that their
ideology is wrong
zionist ideology is what needs to be
broken and that ideology says
that jews all over the israel is the
country of the jews not the country the
israelis
that's the formula israel needs to be
changed
to the to become the country of its
citizens not the country of the jews and
it's not
and therefore to me israel is like china
it is no different than china the jews
in israel are like jews living in china
and therefore when people ask me all the
time when i spoke at that protest in
nassau county that you
played whenever the press speaks to me
and they only really
care about one thing they don't care
about jewish ideology
anything i just told you they came out
one thing what do you think about the
israeli-palestinian conflict and i asked
them
why don't you ask me about the conflict
between china and the yugo muslims
or between india and kashmir you're
asking me because i'm a jew and because
i'm a jew you think i have a connection
with israel
i'll have news for you i have nothing to
do with israel
israel's politics has as much to do with
me
as china's politics and as korea's
politics
and as all of this see it's a trap
i believe it's a trap this is my view
jews that jump into the
israeli-palestinian conflict even on the
side of the palestinians but to do so
because they're jews and they're not
involved in other human rights
questions all over the world but because
they're jews they feel they have to
weigh in
in israel if you accept that if anybody
accepts that you're accepting zionism
because what you're saying is you're a
jew israel's your country
what do you as a jew have to say about
what your country is doing
my answer to that is israel is not my
country
ask me about china listen human rights
issues concern me all over the world
but as a jew i am no more connected to
israel's behavior
then i am connected to china's behavior
and i'm no more connected to the i'm not
israeli i'm not palestinian
i'm not chinese and i'm not a yugo
muslim i'm a jew
and an american of polish descent
i have nothing to do with israel and if
everybody would get that attitude
then guess what israel would not be the
state of the jewish people would not
israel has to stop
claiming it's the jewish state it has to
be a normal state like all other
countries
japan is to the japanese what israel is
to the israelis
that is the quickest way to us towards
peace
so my answer to your question about ben
shapiro and ariel gold is
they are talking about a conflict a
behavior that has nothing to do with me
if i would be a a christian buddhist
that lived in france you wouldn't play
ben shapiro's clip for him
and i understand why you're playing it
for me but my answer is that i have as
much connection with the issue that
they're talking about
as i do with china and and i really feel
in my heart
that this attitude is the key
to starting peace in the middle east if
israel is the state of the jewish people
it's a very big problem for everybody
yeah if israel's a state of the israelis
it starts the peace process by shapiro
can you tell us is zionism
antithetical to orthodox judaism
absolutely absolutely judaism
even reform judaism judaism is a
religion
the definition of a jew is somebody who
the religion claims who the religion
says
is obligated to fulfill the midst this
the torah the commandments
zionism says no that's nonsense judaism
is nonsense
rather the jews are and always were
a political people wanting to return to
their land like
all people want to return to their land
with a
national uh identity and israel is the
state of those people they are they're
they're
diametrically opposed they're opposed
they are enemies of each other those two
judaism and zionism absolutely
and that's what everybody needs to know
wow tell me we we hear a lot you know
modern jews reform jews so modern jews
who say we don't believe in god
moses etc are they still considered jews
because you'll hear
a lot of people who will consider
themselves jews by nationality
but when it comes to god when it comes
to torah when it comes to one of these
fundamental
principles they you know kind of take it
like a buffet like burger king have it
your way
what do you say to that yeah so if you
ask those people what makes them jews
they'll say it's an ethnicity maybe and
i'll ask them is ivanka trump
and the ethiopian jews of the same
ethnicity the yemeni jews and the
russian jews
there is nothing that there is no
logical
uh definition of jew except the one that
judaism gives
these people who want to be considered
jews without religion
don't aren't thinking it through are
they considered jews
the answer is according to the religion
if they are obligated to fulfill the
mitzvos the torah the
commandments then they're considered
jews judaism
according to the jewish religion is a
job
description whoever was given the job by
god
to fulfill the torah and that the
religion tells us who was given the job
they're considered jews so if somebody
is considered jews a jew according to
the religion they had a jewish mother
or went through a jewish conversion in
the proper jewish way it's a ritual
it's not nationalization it's not
naturalization
it's can religious conversion then
they're considered jews and
obligated to fulfill the torah that's
true even if
they disagree with that even if they
don't believe it
but if the torah says you're a jew that
means you're obligated
and that obligation is what gives you
your jewish identity so in other words
when i say jew and they say jew
it's just a homonym they may or may not
be jewish
depending upon if the torah says so but
when i said you and they say jew it's
absolute homonym you know it's kind of
like by the christians you know they
have
the evangelical christians and the
catholics and they have two completely
different ideologies
zionism is further from judaism than the
evangelicals are from the catholics
because
at least reformed judaism says that
judaism is a religion it's just a
different religion than mine
zionism says judaism isn't even a
religion it's a nationality that had a
national religion
the way the greeks worshiped zeus the
jews worshipped hashem
but it's a it's a completely different
definition of what it is to be a jew
it's the furthest thing you can get
aren't there a lot of zionists who are
just atheist
absolutely and ben gurion was an atheist
and
even if they're not atheists they
certainly don't believe in our god
netanyahu
is a completely non-observant jew
avigdor lieberman's anti-observant
guys like herzl herzl hated jewish
religion ben gurion said that orthodox
judaism meaning judaism that
he said judaism that's that's on claims
that the religion is unchanging
is nazi ideology that's what ben gurion
said about my religion
yes these zionist and in fact that was
one of the goals of zionism
the uh founding fathers of zionism there
are those who said
that once we establish the jews as a
nationality religion won't matter
you could be a greek without worshiping
zeus you could be
a um uh a what do you call it a uh
from switzerland or from norway without
worship worshiping odin
um you could be you could be an indian
without uh
be being a hindu and you could be a jew
according to them
without be any religion because being a
jew has nothing to do with religion by
the way
there's a contradiction in israeli law
about this
according to israeli law an atheist is
entitled to the law of return if at
least he's born jewish
okay but if you convert to christianity
or to another religion
you lose your right to return
that's the jewish that's israeli um
supreme court ruled that way there was a
jew who was born jewish brother daniel
he became a carmelite monk
and he was no anti-semite he saved jews
in the holocaust by hiding them
helping to hide them and the israeli
supreme court said he's not entitled to
the law of return
because he doesn't he practices another
religion and yet
if you don't practice any religion and
you're an atheist
then you are entitled to the law of
return which is nuns it doesn't make any
sense
but they have no choice because the
zionists were atheists
and to make christians into jews that
that doesn't fit into the picture of
what they want israel to be
zionism is is a contradictory ideology
they took
a cow and they said this cow
is a is a car it has feet and not wheels
but it's a car
they took jewish identity and said it's
national not religious
but it doesn't make any sense because i
mean how do they decide who's born
jewish
well if your mother's jewish then you're
jewish right but that's religious law if
you don't believe in the religion why
would you believe in that law
so when your typical jew sees such a
huge gathering of fifteen 000 jews and
these are scholars you know these are
students coming together
um you know what does your typical jews
say like somebody who has kind of been
led down this other path of zionism but
he's still he's a jew
kind of practicing kind of not but then
he sees like you know
uh what seems to be a contradiction here
what what's going on here 15 000 you
know they're coming speaking against
zionism like what what what uh are they
are they kind of uh
you know just uh you know shocked what
happens
yes many of them are shocked and some
jews are
start asking questions i thank god for
the anti-zionist jews because
it's because of us that people sometimes
wake up however
that's if they are left to their own
devices zionism
is an incredible propaganda operation
incredible propaganda
i could tell you zionist propaganda you
wouldn't even notice to conflate that
conflates zionism with judaism
and they'll say oh those people they're
just a fringe group that's just
less than two percent and besides
they're misogynistic they're
homophobic they're primitive their
brains are like you know
they don't know how to speak english
well they'll try to marginalize and
demonize
us um you see you speak you you speak
english quite well
yeah i know they hate me for that by the
way the reason why the zionists
hate me not because i'm against zionism
but because i speak english well
if i wouldn't speak english well it
would be much better for them you know
if i wouldn't dress like i do if i
wouldn't
um you know live like if i wouldn't be a
normal american
but if i would look and talk and walk
like the hasidum they would be very very
happy
but it bothers them that i'm uh
more modern i guess you could say and
i'm not bragging about it
it's the way i was brought up it's the
way i am you know
but um that's what is i'll give you an
example by the way of the
zionist propaganda you walk into a a um
you're in chicago right i i think yes
into a
i don't know if they have big department
stores in chicago like macy's right
you walk into a big department store in
december so let's say they'll have the
christmas display right
the cr hanukkah display the christmas
display is always
green and red those are the color
patterns and gold correct
the chanukah display all hanukkah
decorations are always blue and white
can anybody tell me what blue and white
has to do with chanukah
the christmas display that's the holly
the berries and the leaves right
but what does blue and white have to do
with the answer is nothing
hanukkah was the oil the mech it has to
it's the israeli flag
there's no color pattern for chanukah
but the zionists made this that
you should psychologically in your mind
connect
zionism with judaism so so that's a
psychological
subliminal kind of thing i'll give you
another example do you know that the
streets in jerusalem
most of them are named after jewish
historical characters starting from
biblical characters right however you
won't find in all of jerusalem and i i
checked this out on google maps
a street named after moses or abraham or
isaac or jacob
the streets our nace begin the names the
naming process
with joshua because in zionist history
jewish history begins when the jews
enter the holy land
you see there is one neighborhood that
has uh the jewish women the matriarchs
uh
sarifica rocco and leia but other
than that jewish characters
personalities moses
there's no street named after moses
but you have streets named after herzl
and jabatinski and of course joshua and
the prophets and
the tribes who who you have the tru
names of the tribes ruvaing shimon lavi
yehudah
now those are the sons of jacob but if
you look on the blue
plaques on the street corner that
explains who the
street was named after it doesn't say it
was named after the children of jacob
rather it is the the tribes of the jews
that settled in the holy land each tribe
was from one of the children of jacob
it's named after the tribes
zionism is is a incredible propaganda
machine
incredible you know to the jews they say
well you have to support israel
otherwise
all the jews are going to die they're
either going to be brought into
concentration camps everybody's a hitler
hitler
lurks around every corner and if not for
israel
hitler would be back tomorrow in every
country everywhere
and of course in israel all the
terrorists
would just come and destroy all the jews
and kill all the jews
if you ask them that the jews and
muslims lived in peace
for for over a thousand years
and why is it suddenly now suddenly now
that the muslims suddenly these guys
allegedly hate jews
clearly and and suddenly want to kill
them clearly it's
zionism that's the problem it's not
islam and it's not
musl it's not muslims against jews
that's the main thing we have to tell
people
it's a political thing it's israel it's
not the jews
they like to conflate it because this
way number one
they get the support of the evangelicals
number two
they have a it's very easy to say if
you're a palestinian you're an
anti-semite the only reason why
you don't want a jewish state there the
only reason why you you allow israel to
do because you're an anti-semite
it's a political conflict between
israel and the palestinians it has
nothing to do with the jews being jews
and has nothing to do with muslims
i mean how many palestinians are uh
non-observance muslims
yes there are if i was secular
you know that's the propaganda that we
need to negate
israel and the jews decouple them one
has nothing to do with the other
i like what you said there this point
you know really needs to be stressed
that
before all of this jews and muslims were
living together in peace i had a rabbi
weiss i don't know if you know him
i know very well yeah i had him he was
uh here in the studio and he was talking
about he's giving some history
how actually the jews and the muslims
how they were getting along
and they would watch each other's kids
it was like you know neighbors watching
out for neighbors
it was a very um different than what you
see today
and in fact i'll tell you an amazing
story they the chief rabbi of the
jewish the orthodox jewish people in in
palestine before israel was created
his name was rabbi sonnenfeld um
they he sent a messenger to the british
to tell them
that we do not want a jewish we do not
want to live under the zionist rule we'd
rather live under ottoman
or arab rule here we or british whatever
it is
but we do not want a zionist state
the the messenger's name was jacob dahan
you can google
him he was a dutch guy d-e-h-a-a-n
jacob dahan do you know what happened to
him
the zionists assassinated him he was a
political assassin this is not a secret
they bragged about it
they met the assassin they dug him up he
was in japan after the war
and he said yeah of course he he put
zionism in danger so we did what we had
to do
zionism in order to survive needs to
portray israel as a state of the jews
the more jews and the more non-jews
tell the zionists no israel is the state
of the israelis
jews may there may be many jews who
support israel and there are many jews
who are democrats
but there are jews who are republicans
too
and and being a jew and being a zionist
is not the same thing at all being a jew
being israeli is not the same thing
and the conflict is between the israelis
and the palestinians
not between the jews and the
palestinians it has nothing to do with
being jewish
it's a political conflict that needs a
political
solution just a couple more questions
that
we're almost out of time actually gone
over but i'm really enjoying talking
with you
tell me how and what was the whole thing
that was sold now
that brought the christians who were
talking about this rapture
you know much about this and now that
they uh
formed an alliance here and this is why
you have christians who are also
zionists now
like when uh what's his name the current
president said i would
be a zionist i am a zionist you don't
have to be a jew to be a zionist so let
me tell you a secret
christian zionism existed before jewish
zionism from the late 1500s early 1600s
there's a group of protestants that
believe that the jews
because of their ideology are going to
return to the holy lands before their
the second coming of their messiah
there's a disagreement amongst them
some say the jews when the their messiah
comes will convert
others say they'll just be killed and
others have other
opinions but the the jewish zionists
got much of their ideology from the
christians not vice versa
these christian zionists existed way
before the jewish ones
um herzl theodore herzl got his
international connections
he was introduced by a christian zionist
named the reverend william
heckler h-e-c-h-l-e-r
and he introduced him uh to the grand
duke of biden
and many heads of state because he
believed that herzl
was a fulfillment of the christian
messianic prophecies
in fact i got to tell you something
there are many things that people
attribute to jewish zionists that are
really originated with christian
zionists for example
the idea that the jews should take over
israel the christian zionists had way
before the jews
the idea that the jews should speak
hebrew there way before the jews the
christian zionists said it herzl didn't
believe
that the jews should speak hebrew in a
state once he
they create the state because he didn't
believe it was possible
and you know the the um zionist slogan
that is attributed by the way abu mazen
attributed to herzl that was a mistake
it was said by israel zangville that
a land without a people for people
without a land
israel's angel got that from the
christian zionists
way before any jew ever said it and the
reason why one of the reasons why
britain
britain
lord balfour he was a christian zionist
the the protestants look look how it
developed
the catholics weren't involved in this
this was a certain protestant movement
the brit british and the americans
uk and us they were more of a protestant
christian country rather than a catholic
christian country right
the pilgrims came from britain that's
why britain and the us have always been
israel's greatest allies
you know because of the 25 of us voters
are evangelicals
and these are those christians but the
christian
zionists have been here way before the
jews the jewish zionists
stole a lot of their ideology from the
evangelicals
in order to garner support from them
tell me um we see a lot of collaboration
happening between muslims and jews
on this subject one of them was uh rabbi
cohen working with
dr lawrence brown on the zion deception
are you uh
do you know rabbi cohen and you've met
very well i'm a good friend of his and i
actually purchased the zionist deception
but
i i it has rabbi cohen's
uh introduction and that is meaningful
to me
rabbi cohen is a reliable person very
reliable however
i don't read fiction i don't have time i
i just don't haven't read fiction in
like uh
maybe 40 years yeah that was that was dr
lawrence
brown way of uh trying to uh convey some
of what's going on
in this type of manner and what do you
feel about this collaboration that's
happening you know you have
this rabbi with the muslim and they're
you know collaborating he's writing the
forward here you see
a lot of this this happening for the
truth to get out for people you know of
goodwill coming together to
you know expose the truth i think that
uh
muslims christians buddhists
atheists everybody should collaborate
first to educate themselves on the
differences between
and the incompatibility between judaism
and zionism
and the main point is that israel is the
state of the israelis not the state of
the jews it doesn't represent the jewish
people and then yes
collaboration for dissemination of truth
to create peace in the world and i must
tell you in my
humble opinion the best thing for the
jews in israel
would be if israel would become the
state of the israelis
israel needs to become a normal country
like u.s
canada mexico whatever
the all these all this conflict all
these problems
begin with israel claiming and desiring
and falsely
arrogating to themselves the title of
the nation-state of the jewish people
it makes trouble for me too listen when
netanyahu says that
um well avigdor lieberman that israel is
to the
jews what francis to the french he's not
talking about jews only in israel
he's talking about to the jews even
let's say in france so what he's saying
this is the official zionist policy that
the francis to the french non-jews
what israel is to the french jews this
is anti-semitic
this is a saying that the country of the
french non-jews is france
and the country of the french jews is
israel
that's a dual loyalty trope israel is
the new anti
zionism is the new anti-semitism and
honestly what we should be doing
instead of framing the question the way
the zionists do
and this part of the propaganda because
no matter how you answer it the question
itself
presupposes something that's not true at
what point
does criticism of israel cross into
anti-semitism
well criticism of israel never crosses
into anti-semitism anti-semitism
it's like saying at what point does
criticism of a of an individual jew
cross
in what at what point does criticism of
an individual jew
cross into anti-semitism the answer is
when it stops being criticism of an
individual jew
and starts being criticism of all the
jews as jews which is what anti-semitism
is
criticizing israel because it's israel
as opposed to criticizing all the jews
as
jews that's not anti-semitic
what we should be asking instead is at
what point does zionism cross into
anti-semitism we should be discussing
how zionism is anti-semitic
how zionism claims my country is israel
against my will
if i don't like my country i can move to
mexico right i have a
right by international law to choose my
nationality but no matter where i move
and where i go
because i'm born jewish israel says they
are my country and they'll tell you
israel's my country
and if you're an american in chicago you
look at me and you say well
israel the jewish state says america is
not jakob shapiro's country no i don't
want that
that's bad zionism is the new
anti-semitism and we should be asking we
should be writing essays and articles
at what point does zionism cross into
anti-semitism
zionism the new anti-semitism because
that's really that's really the truth
and yes we all should collaborate on
this
again this is true regardless of no
matter
who side or how much somebody believes
in one state two state three state none
of that matters
the the palestinians just are get
involved in the
got it got caught in the crossfire the
problem is
even if there would be no palestinians i
would still be against zionism if the
palestinians would be happy
if there wouldn't be any conflict i'm
still against zionism
because zionism says
that i am not a regular american
israel represents me i don't want to be
represented by israel and its attack on
my religion because my religion defines
what a jew is they say my religion's
definition is wrong
and instead being a jew is a political
thing i i am an anti-zionist because of
that and frankly i think
that that that that is the root of the
conflict that's the
root cause rather it's the root cause of
the conflict
is the ideology of zionism and yes the
behavior
uh if if somebody
does something wrong they should be held
accountable no question about it
but the root conflict the reason for all
this behavior
is israel's claim to be the jewish state
because we're the jewish state therefore
we have to ensure a majority of jews and
because we have to ensure a majority of
jews we have to do whatever
i say no israel is a state of the
israelis let it become herzl stand
that's what i always say they should
call themselves
call yourself herzl stan give up the
name israel find a new flag don't use a
jewish symbol that mug and dovid is a
jewish symbol don't use a jewish symbol
have a picture of herzl or something you
know
whatever you want just leave leave the
jews alone you have nothing to do with
the jews
that is step one in the peace process if
you ask me
and thank you so much uh rabbi it's
really nice having you on the program
really recommend people
uh to watch uh your presentation on
by the way called committing high reason
because
and people can also check out on youtube
you have this has zionism hijacked
judaism
it's a really good talk there and god
willing we can have you back uh on the
dean show sometime in the future thank
you for your time and
for sure for sure for sharing these uh
many truths with with us exposing
you know um one that you mentioned that
muslims and jews lived for over
a thousand years in peace this is very
important that zionism does not
represent judaism that's another truth
very important and
hopefully those people with an open mind
open heart you know
can go ahead and benefit from much of
what we've discussed today
pleasure being here thank you very much